[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
join my wife
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh Christopher Robin
what exactly is doing nothing well I
tell it means going along listening to
all the things you can't hear and not
bothering
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
listening to all the things you can tell
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
yeah I guess before we move on
half-asian where Bill Richmond Gerald a
how are you i am well sir how are you
good well I've had a run yeah it's very
long my wife will be coming home today
yes and we'll be talking about her
experience at the hospital and how it
relates to co vid oh the new rules and
why it is a crime against humanity it
really is I don't know why you're
laughing why what cuz all of them except
for one have to be designated for kovin
oh how many people Hospital of Kovac
none in two weeks but but but maybe yeah
I mean maybe could happen that's lurking
in the parking lot by the way subscribe
to Crowder bits if you guys are watching
that's another channel we have clips
from this of course you can subscribe on
the I know iTunes is an apple podcast
whatever it is all the places and of
course do consider joining my club
atlético that comes from uh club because
that's where chat will be coming in this
morning yes we'll be talking about quite
a bit today uh namely disbanding the
police as they want to do a minute all
right it's a great idea what could
possibly go wrong you'll be fine
I mean you know I what I really want to
know is you know when we talk about
socialism people are look at these
socialist countries and then when you
point out the flaws they're like well
they just need to do it right so then
you just go okay great point me to a
society that doesn't have police right
no no just any anyone that is majorly
centralized how do you enforce socialism
I guess it goes to the point where you
not only can you can't use a National
Guard but you have to send in the
federal military because there's no
local police department and then you go
well oh great so you're gonna rely on
the federal government so your big Trump
fan then huh right yeah you want you a
trump right in charge of the law
enforcement in your city okay you want
any local law enforcement no okay what
about National Guard no so who do you
want to have the final say and how we
enforce socialism
my pence bill bar we walk down with
defibrillators for everyone who talk to
the lisp Hey
[Laughter]
so my question today I think we should
disband the police and I feel as I feel
crazy saying that but if I'd have
usually feel crazy said I'd have made
this argument and told you that nine
City Kansas City nine City Council women
and I asked him a lot of women would
actually vote to completely disband the
police in Minneapolis you would say oh
this is the thing you're putting up a
strong this is crazy no no no I'm
putting up a real man yeah super
majority they cannot be overruled for
that let's go see what they're talking
about on the CNN double the number of
blacks and Latinos in New York City died
which by the way either George Floyd his
death was Co bed related or you have to
throw out that entire ticker no actually
because a police officer was leaning on
his neck
that's my point just like the guy who
tried to kill himself a Michigan Cova
death because it happened to be in a
system I believe it was the loaded
shotgun in his mouth like Ben Gordon
from Shawshank
right exactly wait you're saying that
like the headline from CNN was like the
funniest thing that you've seen yeah
yeah so it was George Floyd tested
positive for coronavirus but it had
nothing to do you think we're being
extreme here that's a strummin know
quite literally we've talked about in
this show just just rewind a little bit
hit the rewind button on youtube which
will probably bring you to john oliver
so dependent actually go through don't
go that far we talked about a man who
attempted suicide was then put in the
ICU and happened to contract covin was
listed as a Cova death there are all
kind of examples like that we don't have
the numbers on every single that's but
I'm willing to bet there are a couple of
George Floyd's in there she's not
writing mass
properly milk mask no no that's an ascot
but what is that Ascot why is she going
with that color and she we've joked
about as a pattern but with the surgical
mask on she really looks like that scene
in The Dark Knight where the Joker just
blows it up and walks away okay so we
are going to get some some information
some facts I'm disbanding the police but
first actually our wonderful editor here
formally in turn even Brendon from what
I understand audio wade we've sent him
out yeah yeah we've sent him out so
obviously with all of the you know
economic downturn some industries that
may have all you know may have been on
the way out already are now dead or
dying right so yeah one of those is the
payphone industry it's been out for been
on the way out for a while but yeah
again so yeah we decided to send Brendan
out and then see if you can find it yeah
basically just see if you can find a
payphone so we can support them you know
a function Porter local businesses
right exactly and pay and unfortunately
payphones phone booths one of the first
targets for looting and I take some
blame because you know allegedly look
like Clark Kent according to street
vandals so right now let's go oh no
Chuck Schumer they're always just I
don't know they do in waiting like what
do you having like a Desmond Tutu yeah
today I need to look like I support
Africa so yes which country where's
Chuck's mask yeah yeah where is his mask
he said it was absolutely absurd to not
wear a mask and this is one of those
things I'll be talking about a little
bit later the code related stuff with my
wife when people say you're anti science
let's happen we have three or four
different doctors for different
diagnoses to to whom were desperately
trying to tie it to comb it over a
little bit but who were we aunty snot
more people anti science when the CDC
said don't wear a mask and they said
Bret well maybe we should wear masks or
were the anti science when the CDC said
you have to wear a mask and they semana
second I don't necessarily think that's
going to work were they were they anti
science when the CDC and the World
Health Organization said the death rate
could be anywhere from two to seven
percent I think the average was some
around four percent or are they anti
science when they don't believe it now
that at zero point to something percent
the point is when people say settled
science that's not an actual thing
especially not in a case like this right
and by the way I've been fine with him
supporting Africa I just don't think he
actually believes it I think system pull
it I don't even know what he's doing and
you know what it doesn't bring it's it's
not his color so it doesn't that work
for him these are not his colors so
let's go now to our correspondent this
is Brendan finds a phone booth there was
just a dress confused that was I love
how it's a European phone booth we had
to go to is it you of course it looked
like it that's very Canada it could be
where I was raised
Australian Brendan are you there sir I
am he did already trash your singer no
so Brendan what what is going on now
have you had any luck in finding a pay
phone no internet so I think I'm close
you dropped Internet so you think you're
close do you think that sound really
exists somewhere we're like the modern
world hasn't touched Brendan have you
ever actually used a pay phone in your
life no well yeah we all we all can't be
19 years old you saw it right cleaner
you have no internet so he believes he
must be close okay I mean in Jones did
it let's look around
all right well even Brendan will check
in with you a little bit later please do
continue the search and I'm hopeful that
you can support a local business because
that's what we're all yeah it is what
it's all about get a haircut
okay the other day I was walking down
the hall you imprinted where's that
beige Rainman jacket yeah and Brendan
had his hair was really long I think he
didn't though it's weird that he chose
that as a cutoff I was walking behind
him in the hallway and he had the beige
jacket you know it's kind of because he
said a knee surgery she was lumbering
and his Hey
was forcing out NASA he he P looks
actually physically [ __ ] he really
was walking like this in a baby part and
he's holding something I think probably
just a big draw spaghetti problem it's
very likely it was penne gluten-free oh
right so let's move on to disbanding the
police I know a lot of you think that
this is a strummin that we're making it
up ya know
so when he just got worse yes let's ask
you more generally because I know most
of you will say well no I don't believe
in completely disbanding the police
that's what black lives matter believes
in and that's what Minnesota that's what
Minneapolis is actually talking about
doing now I understand there might be
some middle ground you might be saying
defund the police to a certain degree or
implement some kind of performance-based
financial incentives that is not what
Minneapolis is talking about at all I
want to be very clear and just like CNN
used to claim to be just the facts yeah
so let's get to real I think we have a
clip the the far left oh my god look at
let's go to see it and really that's
cultural kneeling just standing up I
don't think this is how racism will be
solved yes by kneeling to a mob of
people who have been enough Steven
committed its 25 million dollars in
damage in Minneapolis alone it's called
pandering I'm sorry not kneeling hander
I've said this before if you kneel
thanks forgiveness for something that
you didn't personally do you're a [ __ ]
so it's a pander Dimmick it is the mayor
of Minneapolis came out to march with
the protesters to edit this up here's
how it went Jacob ride we have a
yes-or-no question
yes or it known will you commit to the
punting Minneapolis Police Department we
don't want no more police no you don't
mean that
[Music]
[Applause]
first I didn't believe that was the
actual mayor's yeah Doogie mayor yeah he
looks like a 12 with a mask on he looks
so young yeah he's just trying to think
of how to get out of there
[Applause]
this is why you don't kneel to the mob
and you can see that look on his face
was like oh wow I just made a reasonable
statement they're going to tear me limb
from limb right yeah then they get out
of here before the shove bamboo chips up
my thumbs
I need the police that they don't want
anymore and they walk him all the way up
the police people flicking him off you
are not an ally sir no not anymore he's
so sad cuz he thought he was one of
their friends masks the mob ate him
alive
I brought the game of Thrones I brought
the mask some subscriber Young Turks
that one video didn't you see me we
don't yield to the mob because long
before you get to the kneel one before
you get to like he's playing Plinko on
prices right no the answer should be do
you support we don't want people with
guns do you support the full abolition
of police go screw yourself yeah exactly
yeah are you kidding yeah just like oh
what a second are you learning disabled
token in our neighborhood what do you
want people with rags in tito's bottles
thrown into Walgreens right well I mean
who do you who are you gonna call when
somebody breaks in your house then
you're begging for a Ghostbusters house
we had a call ring ring voicemail yes
you know Police Department right now I
would change 911 - hey sorry we're not
here maybe call someone else good luck
bye guys each and every day
please wait really trained nothing
[Laughter]
that's another example Ben Stiller
apologized for a cable guy you don't do
that because what's a classic so the
Minneapolis City Council they now they
have a veto-proof majority and they
voted in to completely dismantle to
disband the rest was nine people right
nine people out of twelve so they have a
veto-proof majority they have just said
that they have it and they are pledging
to correct yes because you know it
doesn't just work that way
you can't just well guys it's Sunday
night let's just go ahead and take take
away all law enforcement people who
would pledge to vote to disband the
police probably do think it works that
way yeah let me just ask you this okay
all of these City Council people yeah
did they all get elected on Saturday
because if not then they probably were
the people who didn't do anything about
the police before right but now you're
relying on them to make the decisions
it's as if the existing government maybe
you shouldn't rely on those folks
anymore who are predominantly leftist
and are not actually doing anything for
the safety about both without that's
true reasonableness
I wonder if present their actual
position everyone here is
misrepresenting yourself for many
reasons they do a proposed replacement
guy social workers in Minneapolis which
let me be really clear Minneapolis is
the most dangerous city in the state
consistently ranked one of the most
dangerous the United States of America
with a violent crime rate of a thousand
one hundred and one per 100,000 people
that's a man's number a significant
amount of crime I don't like a lot we
see what happens here when police don't
enforce curfew with the right yeah right
Deborah's curfew and police level we're
not going to force it with CNN
condemning them for and then of course
they get to they get to your guests and
rubber-bullet inator on down the line or
if Donald Trump wants to take a photo up
at a church
I'm gonna go dad and hold the Bible it's
not just like this is something that's
happening there and that protestors are
saying this in other places defunding
has already happened it's already been
proposed and I think said it's going to
happen in Los Angeles and also de Blasio
just came out and said he's going to
defund the NYPD as well right world New
York yes exactly right so everybody just
on the subway we're not gonna have
police there anymore I'd walk maybe I
don't know those yellow things that go
by that maybe that's a cab I'd get one
of those in the actual post-apocalyptic
scenario films escape from New York and
escape from Los Angeles right I don't
think they didn't have any police so I'm
not mistaken I think they were just
corrupt because no one's gonna believe
in a you know even in the future you can
fast forward three other years nobody
that we didn't have any police yeah can
we be like Robocop weird like those
machine robots going around being up and
ice would that be cool either way some
CEOs getting blown out the window here's
me because this is one of those things
where where people talk about common
ground I don't know how you find common
ground with people who want to entirely
disband the police yeah but let me
propose something because okay as an
adult who owns properly that property I
generally tend to like cops I've had
mostly positive interactions outside of
Lansing where we've talked about this
where they said I couldn't file a police
report by phone turns out you can what
it was accepted because this was a huge
police union and they were upset about
Michigan Michigan going right to work so
I do understand that there is this you
know sort of blue wall of silence
sometimes and I do understand that there
are some issues with police forces and I
do understand that in some cities it's
more than a few bad apples right in some
cities we do have a split up horrible
for a long time right where police can
protect those who shouldn't be working
that specific job so how about this if
we start with a common ground an actual
common ground solution dissolve police
unions right away okay so let's do away
with that done so that there's some kind
of performance-based pay there for
police officers as we should do in
almost any job anywhere else that's
known as job and hire PT requirements
meaning that people who get into the
police have to be stronger
fit more capable specifically in unarmed
combat scenarios that means let's start
incorporating pull-ups into the fitness
test let's start in quite be relevant
actually subduing a violent aggressor
because you know what happens if you're
not strong and you're not capable and
let's say you're you're a sex is Umrah
leaf higher so people bring in a woman
and we have a video here that we
personally videotaped a video tip was
this 1981 yeah we personally I phoned a
female officer who could be reported if
you're not capable to handle somebody
physically you have to resort to a
weapon you have no other choice it's for
that same reason I think women should be
carrying firearms that women are the
most visible among us and they need to
be able to protect themselves but with
the police force we want people who can
handle physical altercations without
having to resort to a firearm so why oh
why would we lower PT requirements in
the police force or the military which
is what we have been consistently doing
yeah well I mean tell me I don't know
what the stats are on this and so I'm
just gonna throw it out there like what
what do you think is it 20% of the cops
that are bad 15:10 like I have no I
think I know but I'm just saying like
theoretically you like pick a number
okay so you're telling me that 70 or 80
or 90% of our system is functioning well
and I want to get rid of the entire
system to fix that 10 or 20 do you
understand how difficult it is to bring
in a new look at this guy he says
genocide is functioning that's not you
know how many unarmed black men were
shot last year jails I know how about
armed black men yeah yeah nine nine nine
you know many unarmed white men were
shot last year I'm gonna bet at 10 1919
how many how many Holocaust was six
million or eight million six Armenian
Genocide and I'm actually asking because
my source here is unfortunately chained
tweakers college zero more than more
than nine our main engines so here's
based on a lie that's why this matters
when you use bad data when and that's
why we are we are seen as like racist
for correcting the narrative and saying
guys it matters that you have good data
because when you have bad data you say
disband the police right when you have
good data you say fix the police right
work on training get rid of police
unions you have productive solutions
that you put on the table not disband
the police yeah and tomorrow you
robbed all the criminals are going to
Minneapolis right like a convention you
guys just said I rate the matter with
you by the way how do you think the
unions and Minneapolis are gonna like
that for the convention centers I
actually have to have to pay $23 for
using our light socket oh really
a problem should I new I apologize yeah
we can't do blackface what did I do
please tell me what I should do
don't worry you know I this is my this
is my thought
look America was built on
experimentation that's why we have
States we do everything differently very
good and I think most PEO
especially everyone in the rest of the
world that copies our culture our
technology our everything right says
that we're mostly doing it right that's
not to say that there's some parts that
are wrong or and I would say in
Minneapolis if they decide and their
citizens and their leaders decide that
they want to invoke the experiment of no
police and more social workers then I am
praying that it succeeds mainly because
I'm tell me more about the other side of
it about what will happen and a note for
anyone in the state of Minnesota or
particularly the Twin Cities I 35 runs
straight to Texas and you haven't come
here yeah you want to see a place become
like Detroit overnight where people move
out and wild animals take over disband
the police in Minneapolis everybody with
a car and an opportunity to get out will
leave every innocent person yeah
logically we cannot believe that this is
going to work right it just does amazing
though look if he could work that would
be amazing like think about all the
money that can be saved but I think what
our big problem is is that it could runs
counter to all of human civilization
right I mean history and look we've been
proven wrong okay right I mean I can't
think of any examples but I you know I
can tell you what this is that you're
talking of people who let the today's
left lift right the economy because
there's only one party today the
democratic party that wants to disarm
you that believes you have no pride no
private citizens the right to own
firearms what slip at all look at the
Heller DC case that is the actual
arguments the dissenting arguments and
they want too many people want to
disband the police now not all Democrats
including that including Judy Mayer
there in Minneapolis but that is the
Express mission statement of black lives
matter nets but we need to be clear
these even the peaceful protests really
which means during the day until curfew
comes in right for a couple of hours
even the peaceful portions of the
protest they're expressed mission
statement is to disband the police
before they start breaking [ __ ] so let's
be clear they're not going forward
saying hey we want to get to the blue
all signs when I resolve police unions
hey we leave there should be more
accountability they want disbanding the
police that's why the Minneapolis City
Council here have decided to pledge to D
to defund completely disband the police
and replace them with social workers we
need to be clear when you were talking
what are you opposed to what am i I do
logically opposed to I need to know what
their mission is the mission is no
police ever and they're locking arms
with the party who says you don't have a
right to a firearm ever also it'll be
really interesting I am willing to bet
my bottom dollar that there are more
first-time gun owners right now in
America than ever in recorded history in
even the high points are gone
you know times are tough when those are
gone there's a ton of people out there
that posted stuff about the Second
Amendment when all of the arguments were
going on I would never own a firearm you
never need a farm Lee honey go get a
fire it's getting real the protesters
are here is it any wonder that people
that listen to CNN and Al Sharpton and
Jesse Jackson and President Barack Obama
when he was in office is it any wonder
that they think oh man you gave just as
good a chance of being shot by a cop as
being helped by a cop is it any wonder
that after listening to decades of that
that they want to disband the police
right is it any wonder that that that
kind of rhetoric is out there saying
every cop is racist essentially if you
have a white cop he's racist this George
Floyd thing that was racism that killed
him right no stop asking questions and
take a knee [ __ ] so this is actual -
and this is why I encourage higher pto
occurrence by the way for police
officers a lot of times they pass the
very easy test they don't - keep it up
your annual one-and-done you often
wonder like how many times have you seen
and I know some police officers who are
absolutely at the top of their game like
their job seriously listen if you're a
police officer a part of your job is
staying in shape and physically capable
just like it is for an athlete that is a
part of your job so that you should be
able to handle or any very physical
altercation that comes your way case in
point when we use
work at our old office johnny-boy and I
just happened to stumble across this
video of a black man sorry I just have
to say it so you don't see it and then
say why didn't you say in boxers being
cuffed now the video you're about to see
is after he punched one of the officers
once they start cuffing him and then he
punches another officer again it took I
think for officers you'll see in this
video one of whom is a woman who stands
back to tase him and subdue him let's uh
let's roll this clip here
so this was just us on the corner of a
street at this point he'd already struck
a police officer and that's right there
that happens again until finally you see
look they're not able to subdue this
person so if you cannot subdue a person
right there if you're not capable of
cuffing him and subduing them physically
what happens then you have to resort to
in this case a Taser right they have to
resort for officers there they can't
physically subdue them so they resort to
a Taser that's a couple of reasons some
of them aren't physically capable and
their hands are just it goes down there
you go punch that cop here weatherman is
terribly missed up don't we have a
slow-mo of that yeah in case you might
have missed it because a car went by
this is the second punch because the
reason we started rolling was due to the
first punch this might have been a year
and a half ago yeah okay so this is why
I want to be clear because this is the
statistic of where you're talking about
if that meant had been fatally shot he
would be one of the nine unarmed black
men shot fatally by police officers
right you punch a cop once punch a cop
once shame on you
punch a cop twice that's what I believe
the saying goes you've heard that tale
from the sea let's bring up the slow-mo
here so you can see him punching the
police officer give me the knife court
of like here so here you go as the car
goes by you can see boom the swing and
you'll see the finish of the extension
you can't see it that's me right there
boom punching a cops pull again pulling
back you can see the cop recoiling yeah
that's a really tall job to do yeah and
they've got enough support around them
right right nobody seems to be willing
to tackle yeah
when did tackling go out of style well
because what do you think when you
tackle somebody they could be killed
people don't realize that that can was
right I think that might have been right
on the the concrete
layin there before it was going into the
sidewalk no one wants to be in the
nightly news because part of the
statistic where you talk about we'll
talk about that more tomorrow all these
black lives matter examples like
Scurlock the man who ran over a
protester where now they're actually our
eyewitness testimony as I believe some
footage from trying to swerve to avoid a
protester who's trying to get hit the
point is the statistics are not genocide
because it's 919 white guys again
genocide would be specifically targeting
someone of a specific race yeah and in
this instance you need to understand
that would be a part of the statistic
because he was an art but if he got shot
at that point in this case it was a
Taser do you really think that that's
genocide does that really mean that
those police officers in that video who
he just happened to catch on videotape
went out today to lynch somebody no no
it's not yeah and not not every police
interaction with a white person like I
said a minute ago on a black person is
racially motivated and you can't just
assume that in these cases right right
are bad outcomes that happen for
everybody when you end up in a dangerous
situation and you act like an ass right
right but that's rule do we all agree
here that punching a cop twice qualify
it's probably bad all of us for what
getting an ass being an ass I think
asses I think so especially by one that
was twerking in Manhattan yeah ed he
burned down do you see that that's guys
we're not even to the halfway point in
2020 I really don't want to know what
the third things coming Nancy Pelosi is
talking let's go to that want to talk
about Newt dungeons in which they were
kept and if they survive that to be on a
slave ship and its sleazy justice reform
legislation ought to be good Wow
everything I can't wait to hear a white
woman tell me about slavery yeah a
democratic why are they going back to
slavery in March to talk about progress
she still so that lady knows how to use
her master she should show a beautiful
display heartbreaking but beautiful
display but children watch this first
thing little children saying mama mama
has anyone seen our mother these
children separated from their mother
the cruelty of that talking about his
mother something that I thought was
objected to that knee and illegal it was
just a continuation wait subject to the
knee and the neck the mean the next took
someone's mother no this is important
she is trying to tie slavery to what
happened to George Floyd she said that's
just a continuation of what we did then
and that's not true yeah because nobody
can say that that police officer yet no
evidence has come out to say he was a
racist and he was out to get himself a
black man like Maxine Waters said right
right it's important to correct that it
is employees people go ahead and shoot
other people because of this right and
there we have over somewhere it was
twelve dead on Thursday I think now the
number I've heard as high as over twenty
people who've been dead from their heads
I've heard as low as 15 and of course
over 400 officers who've been severely
injured and let's talk about that again
let's preface this all by everything by
something we've repeated ad nauseam of
course George Floyd should not have died
in police custody
I don't not at all knee in the neck is
what killed him it depends on which
autopsy were talking about but it
doesn't matter because if someone can't
breathe and if someone is suffering in
the custody of police officers it is
their duty to protect and service and
they should try and get you medical
attention so like I said I could not be
less relevant bad cop bad actions George
Floyd should not be dead from that
interaction now while we're talking
about mama mama someone lost their
mother it is interesting to me when we
say black lives matter and we don't talk
about the black lives that matter um
that really should be exalted most we've
talked about David Dorn but I think that
we need to get into it a little bit more
because context matters and I think
we're sending a horrible message to
young children in this country including
young black children when we paint a
mural for a George Floyd and no one I
checked up on it no one at CNN MSNBC NBC
ever even mentioned David Dorn while
we're talking about role models in truth
being swept under the rug this
comparison matters because these are
both black men who well one served the
black community and protected them
George Floyd robbed many people in the
black community for most of his life but
both are members of the black community
who were killed and both are related of
course to these riots and looting one
right looting the reason for it and one
trying to protect a fellow black
neighborhood member I think we have a
video here of David Floyd versus sorry
George Floyd versus David Jordan so when
they say why do you burn because wait
yeah why do you run down your own
neighborhood it's not ours we don't own
anything we don't own anything there
they have met Trevor Noah said it so
beautifully last night a social contract
that we all have that if you feel or if
I steal then the person who is the
authority comes in and they fix the
situation
but the person who fixes the situation
is killing us so the social contract is
broken and if the social contract is
broken whether do I give us about
burning the Hall of Fame about Brenda
Deepika target because this has resulted
in more deaths and more businesses
destroyed and lives destroyed in the
black community
then police brutality last year let's be
really clear about this the system is
broken if someone steals from you so the
people are supposed to come and protect
us are not they're killing us was David
Dorn killing you this matters because
none of this is true now are there some
police officers who are terrible of
course we've been through that but this
idea to they go on the media and they
always hero eyes these people let's be
really clear did not deserve to die at
the hands of the police officer but
George Floyd spent a huge portion of his
adult life in prison I believe ten plus
years for violent crimes the worst of
which was specifically targeting a
pregnant woman because she was pregnant
I don't know people who are more
vulnerable than pregnant ladies we have
spaces and expectant mother spaces
jammed a pistol into her gut to
specifically intimidate her because she
was pregnant while his friends
pistol-whipped her and robbed her
apartment that is a level of evil that
short of rape I can't begin to
comprehend that is indicative of a
character flaw so deep it's like if a
dog bites a child out of the blue I can
I don't know if I can ever trust that
person again yeah someone who takes a
loaded gun and aims it to a woman's baby
and says don't scream on my buddy's
pistol-whip you and take all your [ __ ]
that is so wrong and so evil it's not
just somebody who armed
who maybe strong-armed a liquor store
and this guy gets a mural and then they
spread acade on that lie people say the
cops aren't coming in they're killing us
really David Dorn served honorably for
30 plus years this is a black man a
black police officer in st. Louis we're
not talking about Utah we're talking
about an area that is pretty mixed he
specifically served his community with
honor for over 30 years until he retired
became a police chief in a smaller town
and then Wow while black lives matter
activists were rioting looting and
targeting people in their own
communities as she just said David Dorn
showed up to protect them and was shot
dead by another black man and no one
ever utters his name in the media black
lives matter which ones if we're going
to paint a mural why not David Dorn and
by the way if you want some kind of
police reform that people can actually
get on board with who is going to be
more helpful than a respected member of
his entire community who has been in the
police force for over 30 years
that's the ally you want if you want to
protect your neighborhood and you shot
him dead and demanded that everyone
swept swept it under the rug yeah and
and what we're saying here is like look
it's okay if you want to if your Jay is
a symbol of hate police brutality should
not be happening in America fine paint
that mural that's fine we're not we're
not making him out to be this saintly
character and if you do you're wrong for
doing it but paint the mural of dorm
because how many people do you think
died from black on black crime right
every year you how many people is it
white people killing black people is it
black people killing black people it's
nice it's just Dean just one over sent
of the police force are black let me
take over 700,000 Americans who are
employed by the police force and a much
higher percentage of black people
employed in that area of employment than
most areas of employment and
significantly higher of a percentage
than the black population in America at
large again just like looting and
rioting and burning these neighborhoods
that I understand this lady said she
didn't care about because she's on board
with Trevor Noah
you are disproportionately attacking
black men and women who serve their
communities how about black cops matter
dissolve police unions hire PT
requirements and if you want to bring
someone to the table how about we bring
black police officers who'd you know
what to this is just a theory you know
I think there probably are there's
probably a significantly higher portion
of black Americans who serve in the
police force than general population at
large because they probably look at
their communities from people like that
who say let's burn it down these people
aren't helping they say you know what I
want to help and I want to serve our
community that's what David Dorn did you
didn't care he doesn't get a mural it's
almost like when you go to church and
someone gets up there to be baptized and
they have a testimonial no one actually
cares to bring up the person at church
who says well you know what I was
actually raised in a good Christian
household stayed in the straight and
narrow and you know I always had my
doubts but I still serve God in my
community no one cares that guy doesn't
get a mural when those are the people
who we should be emulating it doesn't
mean that we're perfect
but don't hero I someone who committed
acts of evil that are incomprehensible
like George Floyd didn't deserve to die
not a good guy if you look at his
history as an adult two separate facts
David Dorn didn't deserve to die was a
fantastic human being one spent his life
George Floyd regardless of death once
spent his life putting other lives in
danger in his community one spent his
entire life proactively serving and
saving lives in his community I think
one should be praised more than the
other if we're going to talk about truth
and find a way to move forward we have
to check back in with Brennan but first
youtube we're gonna go to Mudd Club
exclusive so you can piss off I know
you're gonna ban me anyway